sending you live now
thank you good evening and welcome
everyone to tonight's uh
virtual planning meeting my name is
danny kendall i'll be
chairing tonight's meeting in accordance
with the rules and procedures as
set out in our agendas
um before we begin i'd like to just in
recognition of the
sad news of the death of prince philip
and in acknowledgement of his
life of dedicated service to the queen
country i'd like to propose that we hold
a
minute silence before the meeting begins
i trust that nobody will have any
objection to that
therefore uh i will start that now
please
foreign
thank you everybody okay i'll add
uh that i'm sure uh we can send our
thoughts
to the queen at this sad time and indeed
the rest of the royal family as well
okay uh we should move to the rest of
our meeting
so before we proceed i'll just go
through a few bits of housekeeping if
that's okay um just to remind people
um that the you need to keep your
devices fully charged
um and please of course mute your
microphones when not speaking
um and then of course make sure you turn
off the mic when you're finished as well
uh please also remember to switch mobile
phones to silence as
i'm doing now so it won't be interrupted
later on during the meeting
if any member of the meeting of the of
the committee uh
encounters technical issues during the
meeting please do
take best efforts to rejoin if you can't
do that then you will have been deemed
to have left the meeting as long as the
meeting remains
quite at that point we will continue um
also please be aware that the meeting is
being recorded tonight and live streamed
images and sound may be used for
training purposes in future
for members of the public it was
established before the meeting started
that all members of the committee can
hear and
see the proceedings and that they have
read all of the relevant documentation
and update sheets uh we can move them to
an introduction of the offices that we
have tonight i won't ask them all to
introduce themselves i'll just
do that for you we have from committee
services liz javalska with our legal
representative tonight
is ross chambers our planning manager is
richard gardner and our planning
officers are louise casey neil hempstead
and victoria kempton richard i believe
you have the brief statement that you'd
like to make at this point
please yes thank you mr chairman
this is just to confirm that my role is
to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their decision
taking thank you
that's excellent thank you for that
richard okay uh
in that case i think we move to item one
of our agenda tonight so apologies for
absence please
liz thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors adam
dixon and richards tonight
thank you for that there's excellent
those are noted any disclosure of
interests please uh
for members of the committee if you'd
like to indicate in the chat uh council
of the mills i see you've indicated
already
yeah yes thank you mr chairman um
on uh item five on the agenda that's uh
24
gardiner road um application
20 stroke zero three two eight four
stroke
uh fuel um i'll be speaking as the world
member so we'll be stepping down on the
on the debates thank you thank you for
that uh council mills uh
council redden and council and seraphin
uh thank you um i've had correspondence
from both the chesterton and the cointon
applications this evening both of our
email which i think most councillors
have had
so i'd like to declare that although i
intend to
thank you i presume we've all had that
carry on uh sorry
so uh i enter both of those with a uh an
open mind and also i've had personal
uh correspondence from the applicant on
the studly application
202896 ful
again i'm entering that uh with an open
mind and
you'll note that i asked a technical
question on that regard on the update
sheet
that's great thank you wonderful i think
that's okay we can proceed
um councillor crump
evening mr chairman um yes i'm
an actor ward member for the felden
award which covers uh chesterton
um i've had correspondence but i've come
to the meeting with an open mind and
will be staying for that item thank you
thank you for that counselor
sarah oh yes uh i have an interest in
the last application
which is uh 20 stroke zero two
eight nine six stroke full as i will be
speaking
in support of the applicant thank you
thank you for that as well uh councillor
parry notes that she's also had emails
from a couple of the applicants i think
we'll take it as read that we all have
and we're all content we can open uh
enter meeting with an open mind um right
in that case removes the minutes uh of
the meeting held on the 17th
uh i give a thumbs up from people to say
they're happy
that we're okay sign those thank you
true and accurate record
lovely i'm getting thumbs up from across
the board that's fantastic thank you
so those can be signed into course and
in that case we move then to our first
application tonight
this is application uh this is item four
uh found on page nine of your agendas an
application reference
twenty slash zero zero four two one
slash ful and it's the land opposite oak
house
all gated road chesterton lunch opposed
to
two-bedroom self-built local market
bungalow
presenting office on this is louise
casey louise
over to you thank you chairman let me
just share my screen
you can let me know when you can see
that that'd be great
yeah i've got that thank you okay
so the application now four members
seeks planning permission for the
construction of one
self-built local market dwelling the
application site is situated adjacent to
the settlement of chesterton which is
categorized as an all other settlement
so the site is outlined here in red it's
situated in an open countryside location
and the topography of the site rises to
the south and the east
as does the surrounding landscape so
yeah
so here we've got an area of view of the
site so it just shows in context to the
surrounding pattern of development
moving on to the plans now um this is
the site layout plan so we've got the
proposed layout
as you can see the development will be
located south of
the existing stable barn owned by the
applicant and we utilize
existing vehicular access
so here are the proposed elevations as
well it would be single story and it
would be constructed of brick beneath a
plain tile roof
this is the first image so in this image
we can see the existing access points
into the site
next image here pans slightly to the
right i've got a red arrow indicating an
approximate location of the proposed
dwelling
this third image is taken from a
position just further south along the
old gated road
this time looking back towards the site
again the arrow shows the approximate
location of the proposed dwelling
and this last image here has been taken
from google street view
it just gives you an idea of the
surrounding open landscape and rising
topography
so to conclude chesterton is classed as
an all the settlement where new
residential development
is restricted to small-scale
community-led schemes to meet an
identified need by the local community
in this case the principle of a single
dwelling is not accepted on this site
whilst it's recognised that housing
needs survey has been carried out
which identifies the local need for this
type of dwelling the applicant is not
considered to meet the need as they do
not satisfy the local connection test
furthermore the proposal would also be
harmful to the open landscape
which makes up the character of this
part of chesterton chairman it's
therefore recommended that planning
permissions refuse for the reason set
out in the report
in terms of updates a legal opinion has
been submitted by the applicant a
summary of the legal opinion is included
on the update sheet in addition to
officer response thank you
thank you for that louise excellent so
we can move then to our first speaker
and i'm
sure that we have all speakers in now so
we can go then to uh councillor andy
turner chairman of the parish council uh
parish meeting apologies councillor
turner are you there
it's i am oh hello there excellent
welcome good evening good evening
so uh you have three minutes um we
please don't hang up at the end of that
three minutes maybe that the committee
have some questions for you
um we'll give you a 30-second warning
towards the end of your time if that's
okay
that's fine excellent in that case
cancel it over to you
good evening this parish fully supports
its application
and it meets all four elements of the
local needs scheme
first element it has the support of the
local community
there is support for this application
with all parish residents
and proactive unanimous support has been
given from immediate neighbours
at hedgerow's ashbury house oakhouse
chesterton manor mill hill house and
flax house
item two it responds to an identified
need
in june 2020 the parish commission with
independent wrcc
housing needs survey in the report the
need was identified for three bungalows
in the parish
this application if granted responds to
that need
item element three it should be
available to people with a local
connection to the parish
the applicant has been part of the
community for over seven years
mary works on her land for over 40 hours
a week
mary is an important member of the
community she allows other horse owners
to use her facilities
she provides equestrian training
services and advice to other horse homes
in the parish
the horse manure from her horses is
provided free to all passers-by
and is widely used by local gardeners
just to remember a farmer in the parish
with a similar number of horses
sells his horse manure at a pound or bag
mary allows parishioners to use her land
to park cars or parish social events
the applicant fully engages in
fundraising for parish needs
i.e the horse blessing charity event
with sons going to the church and the
windmill
chester windmill open weekend with all
funds going to the church
the applicant's plan to develop the
truffle orchard on the land
has stimulated interest from local
restaurants and gives further reason for
mary to spend even more
time working on her land this will be
possible if this application is granted
and with her residing on her land the
planning committee needs to consider the
definition of work
work does not need to be done for
financial reward in a time of restricted
work availability and voluntary work
being a norm
with covid and charity work in society
then for the planning committee to
discriminate against
unpaid work would be at best in congress
there is no doubt that mary cobb is an
integral member of the parish
and worked hard to improve the nature of
the parish community
the fourth element of local needs is
that it should be small-scale
this modest two-bedroom bungalow is
development may i remind the committee
that in policy cs15 it states
sdc will attach significant weights to
the fact that the parish council
is supportive of the local needs scheme
and further
sdc states it actively encourages
communities to take the lead in
promoting housing schemes
in conclusion this application in fact
conforms with cs15
and as10 and it is fully supported by
the parish
i ask you you consider this application
favorably thank you
thank you council turner excellent
timing as well i think
um do we have any questions from the
committee i'll wait for you to indicate
in the chat
just pause for a second
the chat seems very quiet and very empty
in that case counselor turner thank you
very much for your time tonight you're
free to
uh hang out now and continue to watch
via the live uh
webcast okay thank you
thank you okay we move then to our
second speaker tonight
um that's the applicant ms mary cobb
miss carl are you there please start and
six to unmute yourself please
good evening can you hear me perfect
good evening hello and welcome
um similarly to the previous speaker you
also have three minutes to speak on this
if you'd remain um on the
on the line at the end just in case we
have any questions for you
uh and we'll give you a warning at the
last 30 seconds of your time
over to you the tilted balance is
engaged because the development plan is
agreed to be silent on custom and
self-built
therefore any harm but significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits
the major reason for refusal has been
that i am not considered to have a local
connection
i should like to refer you to the
opinion of barrister philip robson
which you should all have received he
reminds us that the terms of any
additional requirements should be in a
development plan document
rather than a supplementary planning
document therefore the requirement of a
local connection should be given no
weight
and in fact would be open to legal
challenge where it to be given weight
however in spite of this i should like
to explain why i believe that the
evidence i have provided
reasonably falls within the meaning of
work i passionately believe that as a
landowner i am a custodian of the land
and a major part of my role is to work
to preserve and enhance the environment
for future generations
since the application was refused 12
months ago my partner has unfortunately
died
with more time available to me i have
been working towards establishing my own
business
developing the two acre truffle orchard
planted by the previous owner
to do so i have attended a course
arranged for a specialist to assess the
site
contacted restaurants as potential
customers carried out work to improve
the site and register the business
as a limited company with companies
house
irrespective of financial gain i feel it
is my responsibility
to protect and preserve a species that
has limited availability
i also feel strongly that there is an
element of age discrimination
involved in so far as i am in receipt to
a pension
and do not need to rely solely on
additional paid income
moreover the dictionary definition does
not require that work is done for
financial gain
the other reason for recommending
refusal is that the fighting of the
bungalow would constitute an incongruous
form of development
i am proposing a low-level traditional
barn light building
positioned adjacent to the road leveling
works will reduce the visual impact
combined with sympathetic planting of
native tree species around the building
i suggest there is no landscape harm
however
even if the committee find there is
landscape harm it comes nowhere close to
significantly
and demonstrably outweighing the
benefits i have the overwhelming support
of close neighbors in the parish council
it has been agreed that the local need
for the proposed dwelling in the parish
has now been demonstrated
i therefore believe that the benefits of
delivering housing as representatives
in core strategy 15g significantly
outweigh
any notion of harm and ask that you vote
in favor of my application
i also respectfully remind the members
that approval has been granted for one
thousand houses
in open countryside less than one mile
away along the old gated road
thank you
thank you very much ms carl uh do we
have any questions uh pause for a second
if anyone wants to go in the chat yes
councillor jennings has a question for
you
council jennings thanks chairman yes
just a
couple of quick ones here how many hours
a week are you normally
on on the site um
and yeah the next question is have you
sold any truffles yet
um i'm probably i used to be there
probably
about 30 hours a week i would now say
it's at least 40 and with the nicer
weather it's likely to be
that i'm probably there all the time
apart from coming home to sleep
because there's a lot to do on the
truffle orchard to remove brambles and
et cetera
have i sold any truffles no because the
reason for that
is that with the covid restrictions
restaurants
aren't open i actually don't like
truffles very much
they don't store so once you have
harvested them you have to get them
straight
to the restaurant but in my application
there is an example of a restaurant
owner
who is very interested in having them
once everybody's back to normal
okay thank you for that thank you very
much thank you
uh there are no other questions
indicating in the chat so i think that
means
we're content uh thank you very much for
your time tonight ms carl much
appreciated
you're free to hang out now and continue
watching on the live stream
thank you very much thank you okay we go
to our
uh final speaker i hope uh councillor
harris
councillor harris are you there everyone
it's so nice to see you all
hello yeah all very well thank you nice
to hear from you again
right well council harris you know that
you know the routine you have five
minutes
um if you pause at the end for any
questions over to you
thank you thank you good evening and
thank you for letting me speak this
evening
you have had an input from the parish
meeting and the applicant mrs cobb
i support their views i believe the work
and interaction that mrs cobb has in the
community satisfies their local
connection
i would also ask the committee to to
read the full legal advice
this was presented in plenty of time and
if any member has not had the
opportunity to read the advice
could i ask for a short adjournment to
enable the committee members
to read it it is clear from this advice
that stratfor district council
has a gap in policy and requires a
development plan
this case is made out in the legal
advice and the applicant herself
for this application should be um sorry
and the application should be granted
can i also point out at the last meeting
council has accepted that work does not
mean it has to be paid
that work can be both paid and unpaid it
was also made clear if the parish
meeting in the applicant went away and
carried out various tasks
there would be no objection if
resubmitted these tasks have been
completed and i'm surprised that we are
back here today
and that permission has not been granted
by the officer
can i draw the committee's attention to
please note the housing needs report of
june 2020 stating the community
has a need for three bungalows one of
which should be a self build
this report demonstrates the community
need
the report was one of those tasks it has
been completed
and it clearly supports the application
for a self-built property and their need
could i also draw the committee's
attention to the committee report on the
e-planning website
under reports written by mr weeks in the
recommendation on page nine
in recommending refusal of the
application for two reasons last time
one was failure to convince that the
proposed dwelling would meet a genuine
local needs survey
it now meets this criteria and two that
the proposed development is incongruous
compared with existing building line
this is not the case and please carry
out site visits or know that the
building line mr weeks refers to
has the following an agricultural barn
two by two story house two by three
story house
some detached garages single-story
extensions
all these buildings are individual in
design there is no continuity
and this proposed dwelling is the least
invasive in terms of impact on the open
and verdant character of the landscape
the sdc
planning policy paper on the e-planning
website consultant
by eve neil dated the 3rd of march 2021
in the sdc planning policy paper it
states that the mppf paragraph 11
makes it clear that where there is no
policy for a development plan relating
to a specific form of development
then planning permission should be
granted unless there is clear reason for
refusing the proposed development
because its adverse impact outweighs the
benefits
a reason has not been made out and the
permission should be granted
can i be clear and draw the committee's
attention to the fact that there is no
such policy in sdc planning
for self-build or it appears in the sdc
core strategy
therefore the planners need to
demonstrate the adverse impacts
that outweigh the benefits and i believe
they have not made this case
and permission should be granted if not
i fear that if refused the applicant
will win on appeal
thank you for hearing me chair
thank you very much councillor harris
okay uh i'll pause see if there's any
questions for you in the chat in the
meantime i think i can
respond that you you raised um a match
about the legal opinion that has been
placed in the update sheet and all
members have had opportunity to read
that now
um there don't appear to be any
questions in
the chat so in that case council harris
thank you very much for your time
tonight as well
um you're free to continue listening
thank you okay right i think
that's all of our speakers on first
application so
in that case members committee do you
have any points of clarification for the
officers please if you'd like to
indicate in the chat
i'll pause for just a moment
there don't appear to be anywhere oh
there we are councillor jennings
thank you you have a question yeah
thanks jim so i just wanted to know if
it was possible though is to put a
picture up
again of the proposed development
did you want to see um elevation during
site plans
hold on there
i think you had one from the one side
one from the road
was it a photo you wanted to see sorry
oh no sorry it was the
i think it's the next one down that's it
and is the size going to be is it timber
cladding
i understand it's a facing brick um
and plane tile roof
okay okay you're satisfied with that
council jennings
yes thank you thank you very much um
don't appear to any other questions or
points of clarification in the chat so
let's go to the debate
who would like to start us off on this
uh excellent everyone's ready to go so
councillor mills please
let's begin yes um
thanks mr chairman as you know i always
go and look at applications and i
did look at this application um
i i i have to be honest i i couldn't see
a problem with it
um the fact that um
lady in questions he owns the barn so
must work in chesterton
um and seems fully immersed in the
community and it is
it is of modest size that's for sure
um and there are other residential homes
um along that lane further down um
and to be honest i can't see
and you know this this uh harmful
uh makes any harm to the open country
side so
mr chairman i i will be for granting
this application
thank you thank you councillor mills
um councillor perry you've indicated
next
thank you chair and good evening
everyone um
i can i can remember being on the
planning committee when
this application first came forward
and i can remember that we did advise
the applicant to
and the parish council actually more so
that they needed to carry out a local
housing needs survey which they have
um done um from my perspective
um i welcome the fact that we've got
extensive parish council support here we
have
support from the community um i'm very
familiar with the site
because it is in an adjacent um
patch or it's the adjacent award to me
and i would actually like to propose
that we go for grants
on this particular application we also
have
to bear in mind that this is a um a
burgeoning new business venture
um so we also have that in consideration
particularly
um with covid19 um
you know we should be promoting new
business opportunities
so um it is small scale
from my perspective the harm is very
very insignificant and the fact that
we've got
support from the community and
for me it hits all the right buttons so
i'm going to propose
that we grant thank you chairman
thank you councillor parry um i notice
you see
unless you've proposed that we grant um
immediately on that
councillor mills seconded in the chat uh
i will however go to councillor jennings
to speak next if that's okay
yes thank you chairman i i do remember
this one
um previously and i remember telling
tanger the applicant that they needed to
go back and that
parish needed to do a local housing
needs survey
it's this uh being able to prove that
you're
a local as it were i would have said
from the
from the parish council's evidence she
has demonstrated
that she is integrated into the local
um local parish
as um as proposal so the
point two um
it seems like a fairly box standard
small house to me
i don't really see the in congress form
if we were to
if we were to be minded to grant this
i would perhaps suggest that we look at
some sort of condition of further
screening
to ensure that there were there were
trees covering it or
will make it make it look right um
so i know someone else already seconded
it but i'm i'm very much minded to
to go along with the proposal here
thank you council jennings uh i'll run
through the other people who've
indicated if that's okay
council fleming next please yeah i'm
i'm going to come at it from a slightly
different angle really
i mean the ladies obviously complied
with
all the requests that she had from the
previous thing but
just on a situation of ongoing security
she's got livestock on there so
obviously to be able to live there and
look and maintain the livestock but
if you're going to plant truffles they
don't come cheap those things and
if it's an unattended sort of plot i
think that's a potential problem
um but having said that i think that
let's say having complied with the the
other requests from the previous meeting
and whatever else
the house is isn't offensive in any
shape or form
it should there are trees shown on the
drawing anyway
uh to screen the property so i'd be in
favor of supporting this
to grant it thank you thank you
councillor fleming
um we go then to councillor mills you've
noted that you want a second do you want
to speak to this
capsule mills uh thank you michelle yes
um
i'm quite happy to support uh councillor
parry's proposal thank you very much
indeed
uh and then councillor trump you've also
indicated you'd like to speak
yeah i'm sorry i'm more than happy to
support this application
it's a an exemplar of
how the community has come together to
support
a local local uh business and also
a local entrepreneur uh um and now i'm
fully endorsing the whole heart to
support this application
um yeah sometimes we don't get things
right and
i think the officers obviously would
would think that i'm sure they i'm sure
they wouldn't agree
uh i can see they're not in their heads
not only joking their offices there um
but you know this is planning balance
and
uh you know beauty's in the eye on the
pole and i think
you know at times locals don't want
something
and we give it to them and and then when
they want something
we don't want to give it to them and but
i i certainly endorse
the the proposal from councillor parry
happy to support on this one
and i think this is a great example of
the community pulling together
to support a local local business
and a local entrepreneur so well done to
all involved thank you
thank you councillor crumb um i had my
thoughts i think i'm broadly in line
with what everybody else has said so far
tonight so i will
also be uh supporting um a
recommendation of grant um
ross can i ask you to just go i know i
know we need conditions
um maybe i'll go to uh richard in a
moment for those but ross do you want to
talk about the
section 106 agreement please yes i i'd
recommend that you need a section 106
agreement as well just to secure
this as a local needs dwelling and a
self-filled dwelling and that can be
achieved for a section 106 agreement
okay that's great thank you for that
ross uh richard um
richard gardner planning manager are you
content with what you've heard in terms
of the
uh committee's justification uh tonight
for going for
grant on this application um yes the
important thing that i've heard
uh it was actually from councillor mills
about the the work point that that's the
key issue
uh which is an issue for us as officers
um
it seems to me certainly from council
members comment that
members are of the view that the
applicant works
in the term works in chesterton um
that would be enough to justify grant to
my mind
and then you've gone on to talk about
all of the other benefits of it the fact
that
it supports a local business uh the fact
that the
landscape harm isn't significant uh and
those would be the reasons to my mind to
to to override the recommendation okay
that's great thank you for that richard
okay i think you've summarized that
perfectly for us
um okay conditions do we have a set of
conditions to go
ready to go with this uh including
screening as council jennings raised
uh we do yes um i've got um
11 conditions i can i can read them out
or um if that would be helpful i can go
through them pretty quickly would you
like to hear
them just really motivate them so
stand standard three-year implementation
approved plans
details of materials hard and soft
landscaping that would cover the point
about screening the site we would make
sure that it's well screened in the
landscape under that one
replacement planting for any of that
that dies within five years
um there's a contamination condition
required by environmental health from
previous uses
two highways conditions recommended by
the county council
details of bins of water but
and electric vehicle charging points and
then there's a couple of notes
to add to that um if you're happy to
delegate those two officers
uh yeah i'm happy with that thank you
for that rich that's okay
uh louise do you have something else you
want to add
uh it was just the land contamination
condition richard mentioned there's also
a remediation condition to go in
conjunction with that just to make that
clear
okay i'm happy with that right very
quickly uh councillor parry are you
content with those conditions as the
proposer
you're muted counselor parry sorry
apologist
apologist chair i was just interested on
the bins
condition presumably that's been updated
in in
in light of the green waste charge
does it because quite often we get
conditions where
they have to provide so many bins or
what have you but surely
the green waste bin will be determinant
on whether someone subscribes to the
green
i presume it will be yes or richard
maybe you want to come in on this
i presume the condition would reflect
the current council by current
council policy
um i i think i'll have to give that some
thought i think the condition is more
about
providing space for the bins oh well
then that's fine
that's fine um i'll i'll take a look at
it councillor parry just to check that
that it does encompass that point you
may
before we issue a decision all right
thank you
thank you casper um council mills you've
seconded are you also content with the
conditions laid out absolutely mr
chairman
not a problem thank you thank you of
course we picked up council jenny's
point about
landscaping um i think and sorry
cher is councillor perry happy with the
106 as well
oh sorry yes definitely totally agree
with all of that because of the local
needs scheme absolutely excellent
lovely i think we're clear on that i
think everything's okay um
liz do i go to a roll call shall i start
councillor kendall
four thank you chairman councillor crump
cancer cronk four sorry had a mute
button there thank you
councillor curtis councilman curtis for
councillor eden council red and four
councillor fleming cancer flowing for
thank you councillor henshaw serafin
thanks
for serving four thank you councillor
jennings
councillor jennings for councillor mills
council meals for thank you and
councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you that's
unanimous chairman
excellent thank you for that list
therefore then the committee resolves to
grant application reference twenty one
slash
zero zero four two one slash f u
l we can move to item five our next
application this evening
before i do so could i just confirm that
we have all the speakers
in the meeting liz or
someone we have two of the
speakers chairman the um we've got one
of the
parish council and and they are first
and then we
have the um the objector the
applicant has not rejoined yet so i'm
i'm in the process of giving him a call
back
that sounds like well that's brilliant
let's let's let's kick off then that's
fantastic thank you
right in that case item five this is
application
reference 20 slaps
zero three two eight four slash ful
and it's for 24 gardner road clayton uh
and the description is for a single
story rear extension and conversion of
the garage to create a habitable com
accommodation that includes front
extension of the garage
presenting officer on this one is neil
hempstead neil if you're ready
over to you thank you chair i'll just
share my screen
can you see that okay candy that's
perfect over to you
okay great thank you so the
um the application site is shown on the
um on the screen
by the the black dot and the application
site is to the
to the north of kingdom so
showing that in a bit more detail
you can see the the application side
which is outlined in red which is a
three
a three bedroom semi detached property
on on a relatively new estate
so just giving some context to members
of the um
existing site layout so we've got the
the semi-detached property here and the
ground floor consisting of a
living room hall and kitchen diner
the garage is to the rear and i've got
some photographs later to show you some
more detail
we've got a driveway to the front and a
rear patio area and garden to the rear
so the proposal is to
extend and convert the existing garage
so the
extension to the front here so it will
be a study
a store and a utility area and that
would provide a link through to the
proposed
rear ground floor extension here and
into the garage there will be a door
and a window and a window to the rear as
well
members will note there would still be
two parking spaces
available on the front driveway
so just to give some elevational context
so this is the
side elevation of the existing house
with the driveway to the front
so you can just see the extension to the
front of the
of the garage
and just to the front elevation you can
just see the association
door and window so to the rear
that's the rear window that i pointed
out to the garage
and that's the single story rear
extension
and looking back to the other side
there's the window and the door
and to give context there's the rear
ground floor extension
so just to give some photographic
context to that so
this is the this is the property in
question so you've got the driveway to
the front
with the with the garage to be converted
with the extension coming to the front
and looking to the rear so the ground
floor extension would be going
in approximately that area there and the
door
and the window in the side of the
existing rear garage would be there
and just to give a context in in terms
of the street
scene so this is looking north so the
um the driveway is just in that location
there so that's the
application property
and then with the application property
to my right where the cursor is that's
looking southwards
down the road
so chairman there are four updates as
detailed in the update sheet
including the recommendation that an
additional condition be imposed to
ensure that the converted and extended
garage
shall not be used as a bedroom
chairman the application is recommended
for approval as detailed in the
committee report with the additional
conditions referred to previously
the final wording and num a numbering of
conditions is delegated to officers
thank you very much excellent thank you
neil
uh excellent stuff right let's go to our
first speaker
um i think we've got councillor ken
pritis from um
parish capsule on the line what's the
produce either
it's a star and six to unmute yourself
gemma we've got councillor gosling in
the meeting
um good evening chair oh that's okay
excellent welcome
uh so council gosling um you know the
routine i think by now
um you have three minutes speak if you
stare the line at the end for any
questions from the committee um we'll
give you a warning uh in the last 30
seconds of your time if that's okay
that's fine thank you over to you then
good evening councillors and officers uh
and can i say what a pleasure it is to
meet up with mr hempstead again and
particularly in connection with the
kington meadows development
um as as we are always reminded um
we must consider the applications before
us uh
and not endeavor to speculate on other
matters so i'd like you to concentrate
this evening very much on the
application that was submitted
um the application form which is on the
planning website
at section five um describes the
development in some detail but it
includes the sentence
garage to include storage and home
office
slash bedroom so even though revision c
of the drawings now just says study the
application
clearly showed home office bedroom and
it's unclear the intention was
at the time and presumably therefore
still is to create a fourth bedroom
um the description of the development
has been allocated to it by the planning
office this states that this
is a single-story rear extension and
conversion of the garage
to create habitable accommodation that
includes front extension of the garage
um development requirements spd offers a
definition of habitable room to include
bedrooms
so whichever way you look at this um
there's a suggestion that is going to be
a bedroom
the planning office which is report
acknowledges that a four bedroom
dwelling should have three ostrich car
parking spaces
and the loss of the garage prevents that
in perpetuity
the planning office's report refers to
the parking of two cars being provided
within the site
which is demonstrated on the submitted
plans and if you
um go back to those plans you'll see
that they
indicate that the reduction in the
driveway length resulting from the
enlargement of the garage
um then a second vehicle will protrude
forward of the building line
and we suggest therefore it will have an
overbearing impact on the garden
immunity of the neighboring dwelling
number 22.
and lastly the report states that it's
also noted from several site visits that
there appears to be capacity for some
on-street parking within the area
um i'm not quite sure what that actually
says
i don't know that it makes the proposal
any more or less acceptable
it's indeed unfortunate that permitted
development rights for garage
conversions were not removed at the
planning stage
thereby ensuring the open street scene
could be maintained
as a pleasing feature of the canton
bundos layout
and i'm sure that the presenting officer
mr hempstead will see the r in here
um so committee members i'm going to
urge you to consider the application
which has been submitted
and which is before you tonight remember
the wording in the application form
which states clearly
garage to include storage and home
office bedroom
and refuse the application because it
doesn't comply with part o
of the development requirements spd
thank you chair thank you councillor
gosling excellent
uh do we have any questions from the
committee at this point
i'll just pause for a second to see if
anybody indicates in the chat
i have one question while i'm waiting
actually counsellor
um have you seen the updated
recommendation to include condition
seven on our update sheet this evening
yeah yes i have i i saw that this
afternoon when it came through
um yeah i was gonna ask do you have any
comments on that
um it would be better than a
straightforward
grant um but i couldn't see that
it's going to be difficult to know
whether that is actually being observed
or not
yes thank you okay that's great uh i
don't see any other questions appearing
in the chat so in that case counselor
i'll thank you time this evening if
you'd like to hang up you can continue
to watch on the live stream
thank you very much thank you very much
good night thank you
uh we'll go to our next speaker mr david
neal who's a neighbor and objecting to
the application mr
neil are you there please uh star and
six to unmute yourself
hello there hello right okey-dokey then
um
same process you'll have three minutes
to speak if you please don't hang up at
the end of those three minutes
the committee may have questions we'll
give you a warning at the last 30
seconds to let you know you need to wrap
up on
on your statement um mr neil over to you
thank you good evening committee my
name's dave neal and i'm the applicant's
neighbour on the attached
side i raised concerns from the outset
that i don't think have been adequately
addressed during the determination of
the application either within the
submitted material
or by the planning officer i accept that
the distance between the applicant has
left themselves to maintain their fence
which is their responsibility is only a
ruler's width
but that isn't a planning issue however
the plans uploaded to the website are
not to the correct scale and therefore
it hasn't been possible to accurately
measure distances
so i have to trust your planning officer
that the distances and angles referenced
in their report
are correct my primary concern one
shared by the parish
is that the extension can be used as a
bedroom the original application
presented the conversion as a study
stroke bedroom
the highway officer visited the site
observed the applicant was already
parking on the road and objected to the
development
the applicant then changed the plans to
remove the reference to a bedroom
and the application description was
changed to reference habitable room
however as you'll be aware on page 82 of
your development requirements spd
a habitable room includes bedrooms so
this issue hasn't been addressed
based on the change of plan alone the
harley officer removed their objection
though i ask if it still said bedroom
would they still object
your planning officer looks very
favorably on the application in their
report
that fails to deal with this issue they
state that then
there is scope under permitted
development rights to convert the garage
to an additional accommodation
however how likely is that the garage is
detached from the main house so without
the proposed extension and work to
attach to the garage to the house
it's unlikely the garage would have been
converted to such a use
the description of development still
relates to habitable accommodation
and the application form still
references a bedroom and your officer
accepts the horror authority withdrawn
their objection
on the annotation change on a plant
alone i've asked your office new officer
numerous times whether restricted a
restricted condition
would or could be imposed to prevent it
being used as a bedroom
and they've never responded to that
question as you'll be aware part of your
spd
would require a four bedroom property
which this would become to have three
parking spaces
your local plans manager joe has
confirmed that the parking is applied to
extensions as well as new build
properties
this is clearly set out in table one
meaning the property should provide
three parking spaces
not two minus the garage your spd is
also clear and draws the distinction
that allocated parking should be within
the property cartilage
with some visitor parking potentially
but acceptable on the road whereas the
planning officer states in their report
that from several site visits there
appears to be capacity for on street
parking
this clearly can fix with their own
policy and would set an interesting
precedent
i have known principal issues with the
construction of the extension but the
utility
utility the ability for the conversion
of the garage needs to be restricted
do not allow it to be used as a bedroom
otherwise it would lead to on streets
seconds already been observed by the
hardware authority a big contrary to
your development requirements
spd and what your authority is seeking
to achieve
finally the conditions referenced to the
officer's report are not clear and do
not set out what conditions seek to
secure
many thanks for your time and i'd happy
to answer any questions
thank you this is neil excellent stuff
um
do we have any questions please i'll
i'll just pause remember
he's burning into the chat from the
uh from the committee
the chat seems quiet mr neil so i think
you've escaped without any extra
questions
and thank you mr neil thank you very
much for your time this evening if you'd
like to hang up you can continue to
watch on the live stream
thank you thank you okay uh
do we have our next speaker in mr sun
thank you right in that case um you
also you have a total of six minutes uh
to speak at the end of that time
uh if you stay on the line don't hang up
so we can ask you any questions we may
have
we'll give you a warning uh in your last
30 seconds
okay so thank you okay over to you sir
all right thank you um i can appreciate
there's been some comments
based on the initial wording and
references of the application
um and though although this has been
clarified this is
still being used as ongoing grants for
objections through the implied use of
habitual living
our intent was or is never to use this
as a bedroom but to be used as a study
both my wife and i are key workers based
from home
i am a contractual home-based workers
supporting critical i.t services
including those for government retail
and financial clients
the promotion of home working is
something actively encouraged by the
kington neighborhood development plan
policy j2 which includes the conversion
of existing spaces
and can be isolated from main living
areas
which is particularly needed as we have
a young family
and i've parenthesized and included a
url for the
um the the the the
development plan uh and that's on page
25.
similar local permission has been
granted again i've provided a url for
that
for 16 gardiner road for an adjoining
garage to be connected to the main
property
including extension we have shown both
on plan
and via photo that there is adequate
room for off street
parking which has also been confirmed by
the highways agency following completion
of their reports
if you were to grant permission we are
also happy to caveat in the conditions
it cannot be used as a bedroom
furthermore if you require any
supporting evidence from my employer
management
in regarding my home working i'm happy
to provide that
thank you for your time and please let
me know if you have any questions
that's wonderful thank you very much uh
i'll pause again to see if we have any
questions from the committee
we'll just give it 10 seconds or perhaps
even less
doesn't seem to be any questions that's
excellent okay in that case
thank you very much for your time
tonight much appreciated uh you can hang
up now and
then continue to watch on the live feed
okay thank you
thank you okay uh our final speaker
is our award member councillor mills
thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you um hello and good evening
committee
um we had before you this evening an
application that appears to look quite
straightforward
and aesthetically pleasing but the
application in my mind
does throw up the question of the
reduction of car parking spaces
as this application will reduce the
number of car parking spaces from three
to two
the report states from highways matters
and parking that there will be a lot of
parking space
the report also says that there appears
to be capacity for some off street
parking within
the area i would assume the officer had
seen an area for parking which is for
allotment holders only
therefore there is no off street parking
available in kinds of meadows
other than with each of the properties
the report says i quote from the
evidence in front of me
i consider that the proposed
single-story extension and guard
conversion
and extensions would not adversely
affect the parking arrangements end of
quotes
how can this be when the parking
arrangements have been reduced in
numbers
we have parking problems in other pairs
in other areas of kind and due to lack
of off street parking therefore
should other residents on kinds of
meadows choose to convert their garages
garages into living accommodation we
could see the same problem arise
where we see cars parking on the
pavements
i also find it odd that the previous
application was for a further bedroom
and now the
application says study i realized that
as a committee you can only look what is
in front of you but it does ask the
question
will study become bedroom in the future
although
um i think the previous speaker said no
um
um sorry uh and the the study would come
bedroom in the future as the previous
application was for a further bedroom
and now it's all habitable
habitable accommodation therefore
committee
although i like the design and does fit
in with the street scene i do have a
problem with the parking issue
as well as the conversion of garage to
create living space
should the committee be minded a grant
can they ask that a condition
to be be put in that the applications
stay
as a study not as a further bedroom but
i can see
on the update sheet that's exactly what
you're saying um
so committee um i leave the decision
with you many thanks
thank you council mills thank you um
i'll pause again just for a few seconds
see if committee have any questions for
our ward member
so you can indicate in the chat
i don't think there are a lot of shaking
heads across my screen here in that case
council mills thank you for your time as
well
okay committee um let's go to points of
clarification does anybody have any
questions for the officer on this
application
counselor parry yes over to you
thank you chairman um and good evening
neil
good to see you um i wonder whether you
can just confirm
how long the remaining drive would be
and also how wide
the actual estate road is um i am quite
familiar with kington meadows
um and certainly when i have been
visiting properties the only way i could
park
was halfway up on the pavement and the
roads i've been to know what the actual
width of the estate road
is and also how the
how i can how can the condition seven
could be protected in perpetuity
um let me just if i share my screen
again um
can you see that counselor parameter
is that is that come up on the screen
it has at this end yes
i'd just be interested to know what the
actual length
of the remaining space from the
um extension to the garage
to the pavement so from from there
where my cursor is yeah down to down to
there
um well it would it would need to be
where the yes
it would be there wouldn't it it would
it would certainly be long enough to
accommodate
the two vehicles which is showing on the
on the plan and the um the standard
because it'll still be
a three-bedroom property would be for
two parking spaces
so it would still it would still meet
that councillor
councillor in in terms of the width of
the main
road going through um
i don't know what that is but that would
have had to have met highway standards
as
part of the part of the planning
application so it would be it would be a
standard width that would that would
meet all the sort of the requirements
um in terms
of the um condition i think there's one
in the
in the update sheet as well and and that
would
um that would ensure that the um
that the the converted garage would not
be able to be used as a bedroom
okay thank you councillor harry um
we've got one more question from
councillor curtis just come here
councillor curtis
thank you chair um neil i just wonder
you we have this condition seven i mean
to be honest i feel fairly relaxed about
this application
but i am just curious as to how
this could actually be enforced
for it not to be used as a bedroom i
mean i just noticed the other day i was
walking down
one of my local streets broad street and
suddenly the downstairs
front room for various reasons i've got
no idea why it
has become a bedroom i just wonder
practically speaking if we
we could put this condition on there
but i do wonder how enforceable how
realistic
it would actually be
thank you chad thanks neil thank you
councillor
i mean um
i mean if if the district council
it's like a lot of conditions if if we
had a report of a breach of planning
control
then um as an authority the enforcement
team would go out
and and investigate um
and and i think we would be able to to
tell from the appearance of
of how that how the garage is being used
as to whether it was being used as
a bedroom and in breach of that
condition
i think it is an enforceable
condition um
but but you know i i take your point
about giving the example that you you
gave of another property with their with
their room
changed to a bedroom um but but i i
think
looking at the wording of it that that
would be an enforceable condition
can i come back on that please chair
certainly yeah i just want i mean i
i would be more in favor of
granting this but i would also i think
prefer not to have a condition
that i think realistically
um may be very difficult to enforce
that's just my
but you know i i hear what you said neil
but i all for a point of debate
possibly in a vote yes sorry jim thank
you very much
councillor kurds your question was
exactly what i was about to ask neil as
well about the enforceability of this uh
yeah
so i think that's a fair point well made
at this point um
right okey dokey uh we don't appear to
have any more questions
for the officers at this point uh so if
that's the case
shall we move to debate councillor
jennings
you are muted counsellor don't worry
it's not awesome i forget to do that um
these uh the owners they can't sell this
as a four bedroom house
they can only sell it as a three-bedroom
house i believe because i think the
solicitors will pull it up
um also their insurance would be
invalid if they were to have that as a
as a fourth bedroom um so it was quite a
risk they would be taking if they were
to average the fourth bedroom if the
house burns down
they wouldn't get any insurance on it um
so as well as i know that we can't
can't put someone there's looking
through their window 24
7. it's a big risk for someone to take
um but again we can only we can only go
on
conditions which we set um i i think the
way covid has
changed the way we work where we work
from
um home offices are a thing which are
going to become more and more
prevalent we will get them we'll
be getting a lot of these coming in but
it's i mean covid it means that people
in the future will be
probably working from home from a couple
of days a week it just is what it is um
highways are happy about the two car
parking spaces
they're worth three but there are but
the requirement is two
and they've still got two so i've i've
really struggled to see any uh any
planning reasons to refuse this so
um i'm happy to propose that we go along
with the office of recommendations and
grant
thank you councillor jennings thank you
for proposing um
we have councillor parry who's also
indicated she'd like to speak
councillor perry thank you chair
um first of all i can totally sympathize
with the
parish council's concerns on this
particular development
um knowing it so well
um and i think if other members of the
committee had actually visited the site
they would understand where the parish
council
and the war member were coming from but
putting that to one side
um i have more comfort because of the
condition
seven that has been added so that it
couldn't
be marketed as a four bedroom house
going forward
um i do have concerns that other
similar properties in the area will
think gosh this is a really good idea
we'll do something similar and that will
add additional pressure
particularly as there's no space for
visiting vehicles to the properties
um you've got to park halfway up on the
pavement and the road
having said all of that there are no
material planning
reasons to refuse and therefore i will
go
with the officer's recommendation to
support and happy to second
councillor jennings thank you councillor
harry um i'll take that as
as as you're formally seconding there i
i note that uh
councillor curtis also jumped in on the
chat counselor curse did you have
anything you'd want to add
sorry no i'm i'm if
the committee would um be happy to
uh recommend or for to agree
um with that condition i'm quite relaxed
about having that condition included as
you say
it has been said it it would prevent the
house from being sold
as a four bedroom in future which i
think is a very valid point
thank you chair thank you councillor i i
would agree i think
i think condition seven is is necessary
in this instance
um i'll add my thoughts i agree with
what's been said so far so i will also
be backing the
recommendation of grant um if there's no
one else wishing to speak at this point
i don't think there's anything other
uh else to do other than to go to a roll
call
so in that case it doesn't seem very
indicating in the chats let's go to the
role call i'll kick us off
uh we have a proposition for grant
uh councillor kendall four thank you
chairman
councillor crump how's the crop for
councillor curtis councillor curtis four
councillor eddon councillored in four
okay councillor fleming
councillor fleming
thank you councillor jennings council
jennings four
and councillor paris councillor parry
four
thank you that's unanimous chairman
thank you
thank you so therefore the committee
resolves to grant application reference
20 slash 03284
ful and we go to our next item tonight
which is item 6 found on page
31 of your agendas questions that we
have the speakers in the lobby list
are we okay with that yes we do tim
excellent thank you anna thank you okay
right in that case uh application this
is item uh
six and this application reference
twenty slash
zero three five four three three slash
sql yes
i'll skip road uh the description is for
the proposed alterations to remove
an existing brick built store slash shed
and replace it with the stone wall
infill extension
to provide secure storage and home
office space
presenting officer on this is victoria
campton victoria are you ready to go
perfect yes if you just um let me know
once you're able to see the screen
perfect's got that
over to you brilliant okay perfect
so this proposal is seeking to add a
two-story side extension to court
farming ascot
the application is the application site
is identified by the black darts on the
map
the red line outlines the application
site which is located at the edge of the
hamlet adjacent to the open countryside
properties are converted to story barn
from the 1980s and the buildings are
arranged around a u-shape
with a two-story barn range to the east
here and a single story stable range
wrapping around behind
proposed extension would be attached in
the northern corner in this position
and in terms of constraints the site
lies within our skirt conservation area
as indicated by the purple line but also
within the cotswold aomb
the two dash green lines show public
rights of ways beyond the northern and
southern boundaries
so this slide shows the existing plans
of the conversion and the proposed
extension would be to replace an
existing brick-built lean-to
which is obscured by a brick wall here
turning to the development you can see
how the two-story side extension would
remain
relate to the host property from the
front and this is the elevation
which fronts the open countryside the
extension would add
two double gauge doors at ground floor
level and a third hip normal window at
first floor
the roof over the existing extension
would continue forward over the front
elevation creating an overhanging canopy
the side elevation would have glazed up
clot style openings
as shown here
so in terms of design details the new
development would be finished in stone
to match the existing iron stone with a
red clay tiled roof to match
existing the two double garage doors
would be painted hardwood timber to
match
existing windows so as mentioned
previously the ground floor
accommodation would create a garage
a double garage whilst the accommodation
at first floor would create a home
office of the master bedroom
this slide shows the overhanging canopy
roof more clearly which would project
beyond the front by approximately 1.6
meters
so photos one and two show the front of
the barn including the lean two
which is obscured behind the brick wall
the top section of the stable range in
this photo
is evident um there so you can see that
and this photo also shows the
link joining the two barns there as part
of the original conversion
so this slide shows the views of the
barn from the public realm
photo number one is taken from the
public right-of-way to the
south looking towards the site um
and photo number two shows how the barn
contributes to the open countryside
landscape when viewed from the
public right of way to the north looking
in the southwesterly direction
photo 3 shows that the top section of
the extension will be slightly visible
from the main village
so in conclusion given the scale and
design of the extension the proposal is
considered to result in harm to the
character of the barn and consequently
landscape quality of the aomb
and significance of the conservation
area it is recommended that
this application should be refused for a
reason set out in the office's report
and there are no updates to note on this
one thank you
that's excellent thank you victoria
excellent stuff um
okay we go to our first speaker which
should be uh council mark burstall
uh warmington valsket parish capsule
council of bursle are you there star and
six to unmute please
good evening good evening hello
welcome to tonight's meeting so then you
will have uh
three minutes to speak please don't hang
up at the end of those three minutes
uh because we may have some questions
for you um and uh you will give you a 30
second warning
uh before the end of your time so you
can wrap up your thoughts
uh over to you then whenever you're
ready thank you very much
thank you my name is mark burstall i'm
chairman of warmington
and also parish council and i've lived
in ascot for 46 years
my property lies to the north of court
farm opposite the driveway leading to it
let us be clear about what's being
proposed it's a very small
linking extension which replaces an
existing brick-built structure with a
rusting corrugated iron roof
instead we will have local haunt and
stone and tiles
all designed to match and blend in with
the existing barn
the visual impact will be a major
improvement but at ground level it will
be visible
only when viewed from the east that's
from the d-6417 ascot road
or from the sm-165 footpath
the old brick and corrugated iron shed
was originally indifferent ownership to
court farm
and the farmer would not sell it at the
time otherwise the developer wanted to
demolish
and rebuild it in terms of size
it is tiny a net increase in footprint
of less than three percent is proposed
it is a single story construction to
provide a garage
and to utilize the roof space for a home
office to enable working from home
something all councils should be
actively encouraging
in terms of precedent ask at manaban was
permitted extensions totaling more than
twice the size
of the original rick barn part two-story
and including garages although this
predates the current guidelines we
maintain
it remains relevant and should be given
significant consideration dormer windows
are a vernacular feature in ascot
45 of all properties they are to be
found on the most prominent building ask
at house as well as on home farm
the cottage holi tree cottage and there
are two existing dorm windows on court
farm itself
the use of dormers on barn conversions
can be seen in many other places in the
stratfor district
including elsewhere in our own parish
regardless of the bias against dormers
in the core strategy our parish council
believes that in this instance
it will give a much better architectural
balance
the part g document states other new
windows should be robust
timber framed of simple design and
should match the framing details of any
existing small door
or window openings this is precisely
what is proposed
the design is subservient to the main
barn structure lowering the roof line
and stepping the walls in from the line
of the other sections
the use of a triangular wonderland
is an echo of the feature to be found in
the north facing gable of the building
at home farm in ascot which was
permitted as a replacement for a tumble
down farm outbuilding
yet another precedent i have spoken with
other residents in ascot and
with they are all in favor
the parish council strongly supports
application
and we urge this committee to do so as
well
thank you
thank you very much councillor uh do we
have any questions
uh councillor perry has a question
councillor harry
thank you chairman and uh good evening
councillor um
you in towards the end of your
presentation
uh which was most informative thank you
you highlighted with one exception that
been an objection
could you just advise what that
objection
was with reference to thank you um well
it is an objection that
um is on all your papers there
it is that one it's not an extra one
it's not an extra one it is the one that
you have on your papers
that's fine thank you thank you
uh i there are no other questions in the
chat which i think
means counselor burst you are free to go
thank you very much for your time this
evening feel free now to
hang up and then watch the remaining of
the proceedings on the uh live stream
thank you very much thank you okay we go
to our next speaker
uh melanie williams applicant please
are you there star six to unmute please
nearly have another go good evening good
evening hello we can hear you
hi great hi so you also have three
minutes
uh please stay on the line at the end in
case we have any questions for you
and we'll give you a warning in the
final 30 seconds so you can wrap up what
you're saying okay
over to you good evening my name is
melanie oliver
and i am the home owner and of court
farm as well as the applicant and agent
of this proposal
we wish to replace a crumbling
dilapidated red brick
lean-to at the property at the front of
the property with a
new single-story garage plus pitched
roof
and much-needed secure storage space the
proposal includes for installation of
electric car charging points to allow us
to move to more sustainable cars
the decrepit lean-to is brought into
sharp view on arrival at the house
despite a non-original stone and breeze
block wall
which fails to act as shield it is
highly visible from here in the lower
public footpath
and sits completely at odds with the
attractive nature of the main barn
it is an eyesore in the landscape we
have
very carefully considered planning
policy and guidance
including historic england's guidance on
the conversion of farm buildings
and designed a very small extension to
respect the scale
massing and materials of the host
building whilst also relating to the
architectural precedence set in the
village
the corner section between the main barn
and its rear stable block was never
infilled by the developers who converted
court farm
as the lean 2 wasn't in their ownership
at the time of conversion
the corner is sorely lacking a linking
piece of built structure
to tie the main barn back to its stable
block behind
design guidance suggests that small
extensions to barns can be considered if
linking two buildings
this corner is an obvious place to site
a new single story garage
we have carefully responded to very
distinct design characteristics within
the village
our closest relative is also manaban
which is listed
where his court farm is not despite its
listing arsenal
has been extended twice in previous
years these extensions stepped down and
away from the original barn giving it a
distinctive character
which is highly visible from the village
road and offers a clear design precedent
which cannot be ignored
in fact stratford's own spd document
shows an image figure 6 as an example of
a well-designed converted barn
it shows an original barn structure with
a step down pitched roof section
added at the end architecturally very
similar to our proposal and the arthur
manor barn precedent
in line with the precedence and the spd
example we have proposed a pitched roof
over the linking extension
which steps down from the original barn
so as to be subservient
most of the original barn's first floor
sits within its roof space
and are designed to echo this over the
new garage by occupying the pitch
through space
to create a home office that will better
facilitate working from home and
reducing our car usage
a dormer window has been included as a
direct response to the existing
architecture
farm as well as numerous other
precedents locally
the dormer window articulates the pitch
roof which improves its appearance and
will allow better natural lighting to
the space and
improves visual amenity and views from
inside our proposals sit comfortably in
the undeveloped corner
and within the landscape they provide a
much enhanced overall appearance and
importantly for us a more practical
family home
since this is no longer an agricultural
barn but a much loved family home
which needs to continue to provide
practical solutions to our storage and
future working from home needs
we are very grateful for how well our
proposals have been received by our
neighbours and
the wider parish thank you
thank you very much for that and
apologies for getting your surname wrong
it's obviously not been listed properly
on the on the speaker's sheet this
evening apologies for that
uh do we have any questions uh from
uh oliver please
the chat seems a little quiet okay we
have one we have uh councillor jennings
councillor jennings
would you like to ask a question
you're on mew counsellor
no worries every time now yeah
sorry uh first of all um what's this
what's the size of the lean
two at the moment in roughly in square
meters
and what's the the size of the new
proposal
roughly in square meters um
the ground floor um footprint
is 15 meters squared the lean to the
existing lean-to
there's a small storage area which is
behind the breeze block wall
which if you include that it's 21 square
meters
and the proposal is 27 square meters
thank you very much thank you uh
any further questions i'll just give it
a second for you to indicate in the chat
there we go no no no further questions
in that case um
ms oliver thank you very much for your
time tonight much appreciated you're
free now to hang up on this and continue
watching
the live stream thank you very much
thank you good evening okay
we go then to our uh final speaker on
this application which is the ward
member council fielding
thank you chairman just before i start
victoria can you put up the three
pictures
through the pictures that i've got in
the same way that you've done
we've got enough on screen now counselor
okay
we'll start we'll start with that over
to you
okay thank you for giving me a little
bit extra anyway i'll start now
this is a converted barn which was
completed in the early 1990s at the end
of the barn you will see
a wall that is not attached to the main
building
as you can see on this picture can you
go to the next slide please
or next picture as you can see
it was built to um hide a
sorry this um this was built to hide a
cart shed
um workshop owned by the neighboring
farmer he used it to store
and repair farm bill machinery this lean
to
the next picture please is
no next one
there this um he used it to repair
this lean to is a very dangerous
um in a dangerous state with rotting
timber supports corrugated iron roof
the previous owner purchased the shed to
put up a fence between the
themselves and the farm the short wall
erected to hide the mess the current
owners are aiming to clear up this mess
by building a garage with suitable barn
doors
with a room above the bay window does
not affect the
does not meet with the officer's
approval however
with regards to dormer windows appeal
reference app
stroke j3720d
called 16131959247
lindsay house radway this was an appeal
on a retrospective planning application
with regards to three dormer windows on
a converted barn john
cockley the inspector stated under
clause
8 the building was therefore already
losing
significant amount of its former
agricultural
character the design of the dormer
windows and the low profile
hung profile of them as simulates
as assimilates relatively well with the
over
overall roof profile of the property and
are sensible to the building's form
and its settings such that although they
may not be traditional features of
such when combined with other
alterations to the overall building
their position causes minimal harm
to the character of the host building
or the surrounding area therefore if you
look at the
dormer window it is set at the same
in the same way except for the plaster
canopy
taking the officer's comments based on
the core strategy
one as cs1 refers to the
a positive outlook from the off from the
council
cs2 mrs oliver is a design
archit sorry is an architectural
designer she has considered the need
for distinctive
design which sorry that is
there cannot be classed as old and
sorry as attractive or sensitive nor
distinct
so what sorry what is there cannot be
classified as attractive nor
sensitive nor distinctive the the new
design is integrating with the
existing building form as the garage
will have electrical points for
recharging their vehicles
i believe that scs-1 will be fully
complied with
with energy-efficient technology by
having a garage cs
9.7 is also meant to provide
measures to help reduce crime and the
fear of crime is to minimize the danger
another
aspect to be considered
cs11 aonb the
aomb allows for development providing
enhances the property in the area
as with cs 9 i cannot see the owner
going against this
and the design which is therefore is
before you will enhance the property
cs20 will not affect the housing stock
it's merely modified and altered the
existing building
by the proposed extension csa
historical environment as with all barns
there is a heritage connotation but we
need to be
they need to be habitable and match the
distinctive character of the village
also included within the clause is a
need to have a creative innovative
design
which helps to secure which helps to
secure
the asset the heritage asset and
integrates a new development within the
historical environment
it will encourage it will encourage to
be
sympathetic to the character of the area
there are
other properties with bay windows in the
area
in conclusion i can only see a positive
improvement to the area
the building is not visible from the
footpath
and by storing the cars in the garage it
only improves
the view of the buildings reclining
matters
by moving working from home it prevents
the pollution on the roads
and damage to the narrow village roads
there is a saving of money caused by the
cost of repair to them roads
by keeping vehicles off them the owners
have moved from london they have
carefully looked after the property
and i cannot see any other than an
improvement
to the area i risked my case
cool that was hard work counselor
fielding
excellent thank you and well under your
allotted time thank you
so any questions for the ward member
please i'll pause for a moment
there we are uh no questions here a lot
of shaking heads council feeling i think
you you escaped without any questions
thank you very much for your time
tonight as well sir
thank you thank you okay well those are
our speakers
um should we go to points of
clarification any questions from the
committee for the officer
councillor jennings yes you have a
question
thank you chairman uh yeah victoria um
there
it's been we've raised the the size
issue here
um they're saying that
currently there's 15 meter or possibly
21 square meter
um building there and that this
extension is going to code to about 27
square meters do you in your
calculations does that
come out to be the same
um yeah in terms of the footprint my um
calculation for the proposed ground
floor
is approximately 29 square meters and
then first floor is slightly less
about 22 square meters so yeah it's
quite similar
and their current their current house
sorry that the barn
is do you know what that is i i haven't
got the
full floor plans for the the u-shape of
the single story rear bit
um so i've based it off the calculations
of the two-storey barn
um my calculations for the whole of the
two-story barnes
is approximately 212 square meters um so
at ground floor
uh approximately 106 square meters but
um
if i if i get my screen at that that um
doesn't include my calculations doesn't
include the
single story um sections at the rear
so
sorry bear with me no problem it's just
just
ready it's just to sort of get an idea
of the scale the scale of this bit
yeah so my calculations take into
account the the existing barn here
and the proposed extension here it
doesn't take into account
um the u-shape of the barn so the single
story
ranges to the rear excellent thank you
very much
there we go thank you uh they don't
pitch to any other any other question
oh yes one more question councillor
henshaw seraphin
just in time yes what's your question
sir
yeah um victoria can we have um
the front elevation picture back up for
the design
please um yeah let me just share my
screen again
so there's the proposed one there
yeah yeah so there's already existing
dormer windows
and that one matches doesn't it it is
match
yeah okay that's all i wanted to know
thank you
thanks peter uh any of the questions
paul's reset doesn't like we've got any
right let's go to uh the debate who
wants to start on debate
then councillor mills council mills you
want to start over to you sir
yes thanks mr chairman yes um
i bore everybody by saying i've looked
at this application which i have
um not too far from where i live um
yes that uh this they lean to at the
moment it's hardly lean to me
is it's extremely tattoos it's a real
mess
and of course the war that's shown there
is um
is breeze block faced by um cotswold
stone so
it doesn't look good at all um
this this application i mean if it's if
it's granted
i it won't be that visible from um
i mean if you've got to drive right up
to the to the drive to actually see it i
mean
it could be a heck of a long way uh to
see it face on and then you're not gonna
see it at all
um it's tucked away um
i don't think it harms the surrounding
area
um design looks good i think my look of
the barn has had alterations in the past
um i think this is a vast improvement to
be honest
um it has support from the parish
council um
i said there's one objection but has a
support from residents um
so mr chairman i i would actually like
to support this application thank you
is that a proposition counselor yes i
think so yes
thank you for that lovely um counselor
eddon has indicated he'd like to speak
as well counselor adam
thank you chair much along the lines of
councillor mills really
um i don't think the scale is too um
intrusive i think the design is actually
you know elegant and sensitive although
that's obviously my personal opinion
um i do think it's a vast improvement
and
and i've i'd happily uh second councilor
mills
thank you councillor and uh
so we now have a question sorry point
from councillor fleming
yeah i'm just almost echoing what the
previous two guys have
said um i can see nothing but
improvement in this
uh proposal um i i i wouldn't want
what's there on the side of my house and
i would be concerned that the damage it
would be doing to that gable end wall
um so from my perspective like i said i
see nothing but improvements
uh i'm i'm not altogether clear on on
the planning regs really but
um i would support this uh as a
grant thank you thank you councillor
fleming
um i think i'm i'm in agreement with
everything that's been said so far
um so i i will also be supporting uh the
um proposition of grant before we get to
that i'm gonna
turn to um sorry richard gardner our
planning manager to see if you've got
anything to add are you content
richard that you uh understand the
thinking of the count of the committee
on this i'm trying to look i'm just
looking through the recommendation i'm
basically saying
we you can reverse what the
recommendation
uh say effectively that we don't find it
to be in congress design
and we find it to be an acceptable level
of harm or no no
level of harm at all and actually would
that uh improve the
the uh setting as it is at the moment
are you happy with that richard um yeah
i'm comfortable mr chairman i'm
conscious
am i sorry um i'm comfortable with what
i've heard from committee
um your policy says extensions to bound
conversions will not normally be
acceptable
i've heard circumstances from various
members on this committee
around the scale not being too intrusive
being an improvement on an untidy
situation
so i'm reading it this isn't a normal
situation and therefore there's
justification for supporting it
fantastic thank you okay uh that's good
uh and do
we have a set of conditions ready to go
i understand
if you can run through those for me as
well
do we have a set of conditions to go
with it
um i'm looking through
just a standard time limit and then
obviously um plans
details to match the plans materials to
match the existing but also a stone
condition to match the existing
um and then a condition that regarding
the climate change
and then just a couple of notes and go
on a red line and public rights of way
and then pppf
that's what i i'm happy with those thank
you um
councillor mills councillor eden uh i
presume you're
both happy with that as well you want to
give me a thumbs up how to do yes fine
with me thank you
thanks fantastic counselor
council threatening you content with the
conditions
i'm struggling to get you
i think he's um he's frozen counselor
adam
are you content i'm back
i didn't hear a lot of that but i'd
imagine that i probably am if councillor
mills is
that's fine i think we'll take that as
read that's okay
uh we were just agreeing to the
conditions standard set of conditions
effectively that's great
okay i think we're comfortable with this
let's
go to a vote then um liz if you're ready
i'll kick yourself
we have a proposal to grant with a set
of conditions
proposed by councilmember secondly by
council redden councillor kendall four
thank you chairman councillor crump
jones drunk for
thank you councillor fleming councillor
fleming for
councillor hendrich serafin council
henshaw seraphin for
councillor jennings councillor jennings
support
thank you councillor mills council mills
for
and councillor barry councillor parry
four
thank you that's unanimous chairman
excellent thank you very much for that
liz
uh therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference
twenty slash zero three five four three
slash
f and we're ready and poised to go to
item seven
chairman can i can i thank the committee
for the result and just point out that
the chairman of the council
insists that anybody who doesn't unmute
has to put a pound in his charity vocals
all right thank you councillor fielding
we'll we'll keep that on
in mind okay can i confirm we've got the
speakers please uh and for the next
application we do both speakers are
internal
thank you and excellent right let's move
on now
uh okay this is the item seven found on
page forty one
application reference twenty slash thank
you zero
okay
thank you okay uh application reference
twenty slash
zero two eight nine six slash ful
and this is for the nook birmingham road
maple borough green
and is for a bedroom and bathroom
extension
uh to existing attached garage
presenting officer neil hempstead again
neil if you're ready
over to you thank you chairman um
if you can let me know and you can see
that on the you can see that far away
great stuff thank you
so the um the application site is marked
with the um the black circle on the
on the plan and he's in maplewood green
close to um redditch and to
studly so to give the application site
which is outlined in red
in a bit more context you can see that
it's it's
an existing dwelling within within a row
of existing houses there
which is within the green belt and
special landscape area
so just to give some context this is the
the existing plans so um we have the
main dwelling
and we have a garage and um extension to
the living room and the first
floor um extension is proposed to go
immediately above this
and will effectively infill the area
here and along the
the width there so
looking at the the proposed plans
you can see it first floor level here
there's a
additional bedroom and bathroom
so the extension will be set down
and from the front of the property
however as detailed in the committee
report the proposed extension together
with the previous extensions
are considered to represent a
significant
and cumulative increase in volume over
the original dwelling house
so just to give some context to um to
members in terms of photographs so this
is the
existing dwelling here and the proposed
extension will be going here
so this is the existing rear extension
so the extension is proposed to go above
the existing ground floor extension here
and so this is the to give some context
with the um
nearest adjoining residential property
which you can see there so the extension
will be going in there
and just to give some context within the
within the street scene so this is the
application property here
so the extension will be in filling this
area here
so again looking back that shows the
area there
and members will be aware from the
committee report that objection has been
raised on the grounds that officers are
not satisfied that the proposed
extension can be considered to be small
scale
and therefore constitutes inappropriate
development in the green belt
officers do not consider that the very
special circumstances put forward by the
applicant
outweigh the harm to the green belt by
virtue of inappropriateness and harm to
the openness
officers therefore conclude that the
application fails to conform to the
development plan
associated guidance and to the aims and
requirements of the mppf
chairman there are four updates as
detailed in the committee update sheet
and chairman the application is
recommended for refusal for the reasons
stated in the offices committee report
thank you
neil thank you very much excellent right
so we go then to our first speaker on
this application
uh councillor maureen berry from
mapleberry green
parish council councillor berry you
there
it's star and six to unmute yourself
yes good evening hello welcome
right so yes i'm here lovely well you'll
have three minutes to address the
committee in a moment
uh at the end of that three minutes
please don't hang up because we may have
some questions
and we'll give you a warning in the
final 30 seconds
to give it so you can wrap up what
you're saying is that okay okay
okay right fine to you
do i start now oh counselor barry can i
ask you just before you start
to mute the live feed that you've got
going on in the background because it'll
be a bit distracting
councillor and resident and i wish to
give knucklebrook parish council support
to this application
i would like to bring to the the
attention the following information
um over the last seven months
over the last seven months the following
planning applications have been granted
in mathematics iv
service village all of which the
residents and the council have objected
to
a 66-bed nursing home where the planning
office of victoria chadway
admitted that to get enough space to
incorporate a car park
she would allow this to be constructed
in designated green open basic space
also outside the cartilage of the
village
four detached houses have been
constructed in the garden of an existing
home
next to the 18th century church changing
the vista from that ancient building
five detached houses at chapel farm
where only one previously existed
a proposed development of 236 houses
north of the dog island
which is granted would involve the
cutting down of the woods and all the
ecology that would be lost
i would also request the committee not
to forget the removal of 72 hectares of
green belt
given over to the amazon construction
which started in 2019
the above have all had objections
received by the planners from the
resident residents
parish councillors district councillors
county councillors
as these and i would deem these
developments to be
large whereas the application for mr and
mrs vincent
being a bedroom and a bathroom above a
garage which is incorporated in the
existing footprint of the
property i would consider a minor
intrusion
by comparison i hope the committee will
view this application with common sense
and
see fit to grant as neighbours have
written to yourselves voicing their
support
for this application thank you very much
councillor barry thank you very much uh
i'll pause for a second and see if we
have any questions
from the committee can you just wait for
a moment
councillor jennings question
yep thank you very much chairman thank
you so council
um i presume you you've been to the this
property you you know it well
i know it well yeah
right so you're the neighbor are you no
i'm not the neighbor no
i'm sorry i i know i know the neighbors
this house on a regular basis um
but i it's quite a sharp bend there so i
never actually bothered to look to my
left because they
would end up right around a lampo
somewhere
but uh the property um next door is so
it's a smaller smaller area isn't it
it's a narrower property no it's exactly
the same size
okay and it has extensions at the back
as well
okay that's interesting thank you very
much
okay uh i don't think we have any other
questions unless they're going to
indicate right now in the chat i'll just
pause for a moment councillor hold on
okay nope i think
i think you're free to go counsellor so
thank you very much for your time
tonight
if you can hang up on the phone now and
continue to watch on the live feed
okay thank you very much thank you good
evening good evening
okay we'll go now to our next speaker um
mrs vincent please mrs vincent are you
there
do i believe is the applicant mrs
vincent you need to press star and six
to unmute your phone
house wait a moment
hello can you hear me perfect hello mrs
vincent
hello hello so
you have three minutes as well if you
make sure you stay on the line at the
end
so we can ask you any questions we may
have and uh we'll give you a warning at
the last 30 seconds so you can wrap up
your thoughts
counselor sorry counselor i've i've got
a presentation
um speaking of the um the app can put
forward so
if i can just share my screen please
neil thank you that's excellent thank
you for that
okay brilliant can you can you see that
i can see that mrs vincent we've we've
got your uh presentation in front of you
in front of us now okay thank you again
okay well you can begin whenever you're
ready
okay thank you and i'll come to you this
evening with a plea from a family in
need
we're a family of four with one son and
one daughter
and now our daughter is 13 she needs to
have her own bedroom
separate from her brother because it's
only a two bedroom property
we've looked at the property and gained
advice from consultants
and architects to see how we can arrange
the house as it currently is
but there's no way we can form a third
bedroom without an extension
we have established ourselves in
macavore green as villagers we
absolutely love it
and we're there for the neighbours in
the community our daughter attends a
local secondary school and my husband's
a carpenter in and around redditch
we've got a permanent attachment to this
area our neighbours are wonderful
and have given us their support and the
parish council thank you have all
also given us their support we we find
it very very difficult to understand the
planning department's contradictory
rules
on green belt restrictions whereas our
extension is classed as ruining the view
but other more larger developments are
being allowed
in the village such as the neighbour
who's allowed to build four houses in
his garden
the building of the care home and it
also surprises us to hear that
they're saying we're ruining the view
but the planning officer has never
actually been to
our house to have a look um at what
we're asking for
and where we live um we are querying the
calculations used
um in my presentation i did show an
email where the planning enact officer
has contacted our neighbours to try and
determine sizes
um we request these figures should not
be used as part of the decision
because they can't be substantiated and
the green belt area was decided in 1975
and it's possible that the downstairs
bathroom and kitchen were done around
1970
we don't think that should be used in
the permitted development calculations
um and it does say that the policy does
say
is there's not a clearly defined
proportional figure stipulating what
level of increase is considered small
scale
the government advice has really changed
to say that homeowners should be allowed
to extend
um and you know just i've seen things in
the press that say we could build two
stories on top of our house
we'd never want to do that we'd never
want to upset our neighbours
and look for anything as ugly as that
the plant extension is subservient to
the road it doesn't result in any
overbearing impacts on any angle
there's no adverse impacts in respect of
light
overshadowing overshadowing and look we
cannot afford to move house
to get the family home we need there is
a distinct lack of affordable
three-bedroom houses in muttonburg green
and an extension is our only option of
staying there
can we please ask you to grant this
planning application and thanks very
much for listening thank you
thank you mrs vincent excellent start um
i'll pause for a second and
ask for any questions from the committee
if we just
pause for a moment and see if anything
appears in the chat
which seems quiet
so in that case mrs vincent i think you
escaped without any questions tonight
thank you very much for your time though
it's been very much appreciated um if
you want to hang out
now and continue to watch on the live
feed that will be excellent thank you
okay thanks very much bye-bye bye
okay excuse me um we'll go to our final
speaker on this application which is the
ward member couch councillor henshaw
seraphim
councillor thank you excellent
you have five minutes um and you know
the routine over to you sir
yeah uh i've supported this application
from the beginning for a modern
day living family home it is a necessity
as two bedrooms are not enough to
accommodate
two children i did in the past
ask um the case officer richard lambert
to come out and meet me there which he
refused
so he hasn't been at all i find that
strange that
really a case officer should at least go
and have a look
at what he's uh referring to i totally
agree with the last two speakers
in what they say that um all these other
various developments have gone in
in mapabura green uh which are
more overbearing than this and
this does not impede on the green belt
if you were to go across the road which
is quite difficult
you you would see nothing that impedes
on the green belt you might see a bit of
sky
because it's more or less surrounded by
houses
um so simply i'll keep it short
and i will ask the committee to use
common sense on this
for a family home for this family that
want to stay within the village
um i think it would enhance anyway and
i'll leave it to your discretion thank
you
thank you councillor right do we have
any questions for our ward member uh
councillor jennings quick off the mark
over to you yeah thanks chairman
uh councillor um backing on
there i'm interested to know what's
going on at the rear of the property
um is that am i correct that it's
um not fields as such is this someone's
garden is that is that right yes
it is garden yes so there's no no
there's no open it's not in the middle
of open fields behind it's just gardens
other other properties
yes that's right it's pratt's lane isn't
it up there
uh pratt's line up there yes yeah yeah i
know it well yeah
okay thank you very much thank you
thank you uh any further questions i'll
pause for a couple of moments
if you want to indicate that the chat
seems quiet in which case i'll assume
there are no further questions
council councillor hensha seraphin thank
you very much for your time tonight
thank you
brilliant okay committee let's go points
of clarification any questions for the
officers please
council mills question
yes thanks jim um neil um
can you give me the overall
uh size of the area
extra yeah so for this proposed
development and how and what is the
proportion to the existing
building is it a third more half more
well um in terms
of the the measurements the the ones
that i have
from the um from the
from the case officer which is which is
the only ones i can
i can really give you
the original volume of the house is
is estimated at 211.5
um that would be cubic meters
and the proposal is
estimated approximately 368
with all the extensions
added as well because what you've got to
take on what you've got to take into
account
is the extensions which have taken place
you know onto the original building as
built
does that does that make sense
counsellor
no not to me no so
can you give me those figures again
please neil
the figures of the house itself is how
many cubic metres
well what i've been given is the
original is 211.5
right and the proposed
new figure of 368 which takes into
account all the
additional extensions which have taken
place to the property
so those are at the rear and to the side
oh that okay
okay thank you thanks neil thanks very
much
so just to clarify neil if i can hop in
on the back of that
council mills so you're saying that the
the
new updated 368 figure
is talking about the kitchen extension
at the back that was mentioned earlier
on
it was probably in 19 years it's taking
all it's taken all the extensions into
account
i completely understand thank you very
much that's brilliant thanks
okay uh any further questions we've
gotten uh councillor jennings
uh point of clarification
um i know under the the the new pumice
developments and they all it's always
all over the press and we had a little
um talk on it that you can build up now
would they be entitled to build an extra
floor on top of
on top of this on top of their existing
house
i can probably answer this one neil i
don't think they would
because there's a cut-off point for
those new pd rights 1948
and the properties is clearly pre-war so
i i don't think this one would qualify
there may be other caveats but it
certainly wouldn't meet that one
okay right
okay any further questions no i think
that seems quiet
in which case let's go to the debate on
this then please who wants to start us
off
thank you everybody uh councillor mills
you you're in gosh
just in time thank you um
yes um a couple of meetings ago we had
um an application very similar to this
where
they wanted um extension on the side of
the house and
sort of wrap around and
it was quite a huge uh extension and
um we granted it but this one to me
appears to be a smaller extension uh it
doesn't look
out of character and as um counter
jennings
alluded to earlier that it you know it
doesn't back onto countryside so the uh
the houses at the back there's no views
ruined um they've got a great long
driving about as many cars as they like
by the look of it so that's
not a problem um personally i can't see
a problem with this uh application mr
chairman thank you
thank you councillor mills uh councillor
curtis
thank you um yeah i completely agree
with councilman mills and i'm just
looking
um the policy cs10
um a
subject to it not being harmful to the
openness of the green belt i find it
difficult to see
that this really harms the openness of
the green belt
and just looking at point 0.419
in there it says the council had
previously applied a 30
maximum threshold relating to scale of
extension
and however it's considered that this is
in many senses
arbitrary and a more appropriate means
of maintaining
openness is to consider proposals on a
case-by-case basis
so i would hope that that would allow
the committee
to allow this without having to take
into account that those
rather narrow percentages and certainly
i
and i'm in the middle of moving at the
moment it's a fantastically expensive
exercise as i'm sure
many of us know and if we can help this
family avoid that
additional expense i know that's not a
planning reason
but i would certainly support this
proposal thank you chad
thank you councillor curtis uh
councillor ed
please thanks chair uh yep
again i'm in agreement with the other
two councillors on this one i'd say
i think it's unfortunate that though the
original extensions that are being
counted
were probably there before the green
belt was established i don't really feel
that it's washed over by greenbelt
particularly
and i think if we needed a very special
circumstance to overcome the green belt
i think
you know having two children of
differing sex
in a two-bedroom property and being
unable to move
might well be that lever that we need to
to get around that um that's my thoughts
i would in fact propose to grant if
that's
possible
um thank you counselor i didn't
apologize you had a
little technical glitch thank you so
i'll take the proposal there
um oh gosh everybody's jumping in here
okay
council jennings you want to add
something
yeah i'm not i'm i'm looking at this and
i know that the rules are rules
and it is green belt but it's all it's
also
there we have to judge it's up to us as
a
as a committee to judge the harm
on which it's doing to the green belt
um struggling on this one and i don't
i'm struggling so i'm struggling to see
the harm it's doing to the openness of
the green belt
um i drive along this road um
regularly as i've already said um you
certainly don't feel like you're driving
through the green belt but i appreciate
it it's a green belt
um it's sort of it's quite a it's a very
very busy
uh busy road um i'm struggling a bit on
this one
and then i've always thought it would be
a lot easier if we did have
figures which we had to stick to um
it would make life a lot easier if we
had its own
it has to be x percent and then we can
it's very easy to make these judgment
calls
but when it's very open like this
um and when it's down to our what we as
a committee
feel is a is right or wrong
it makes it more difficult so uh yeah
i'll continue to listen to the rest of
the debate
thank you councillor jennings um i've
got two more people registered here so
we've got councillor mills next
and uh he's seconding i believe the
proposal from councillor eden councilman
mills anything to add
uh no mr chairman no thank you cute
councillor parry
you've all indicated you'd like to speak
do you want to speak here
thank you chair um well obviously
listening to
to colleagues um
there's very strong community support
for this particular
application and i do feel very strongly
in terms of the special circumstances
which i see
as that the current accommodation
is not suitable for the family because
of the gender split
of of their their young family
i don't see it causing harm to the green
belt
um and i think there is an element of
of common sense here and i think i i
don't believe it it will be overbearing
and i think as i say the special
circumstances
are in the family's need um this is not
a this is not a luxurious
extension this is a an extension to
to service need and therefore i think
that does
in today's society um
represent special circumstances um
particularly when you consider you know
you've got teenage
children involved um so i i
i'm i'm going to go against the
officer's recommendation and support
this because i do think
special circumstances reflect individual
family need
and i think we're here as committee um
we are here to look at the balance and i
think that need
is clearly very evident and
with the support of the local community
reinforces that
thank you councillor harry uh i'm gonna
go to uh
the offices perhaps on this one neil or
richard
you you've heard what the committee have
said i'm in uh minded to agree with them
actually um
i've been trying to jot together a form
of words which you're probably far
better at this
given that you've been listening to the
debate but i'm coming down along the
side of
the committee feels there's some small
impact on the green belt but that impact
is not significant in terms of its harm
to the openness of the green belt in any
way
um i'm a bit i'm not sure about the
special circumstances of the family
because i'm i
mind
arbitrarily change that but i would
welcome either richard or neil your
views on what i've just said there and
indeed what the rest of the community
said um if it helps um there's so
there's two stages to the decision
making process here firstly you have to
consider whether it's inappropriate
development in the first place
and um to be not inappropriate it would
have to be a proportionate extension
and that's why you see in the report
mention of the 72 increase above the
original
as it existed in 1948 iv on extended
building
um that 72 figure um
we shouldn't slavishly adhere to it like
our old 30
figure but in office's view 72 percent
is a disproportionate
increase if members disagree that it's
not disproportionate
then that that would be enough to be
able to grant it
because then it would be not
inappropriate development
the second part of it is if you did
decide that that was disproportionate
then you've decided it's inappropriate
development and you need very special
circs
i have some difficulties here from what
i've heard because to be very special
circs they do have to be just that very
special
and to be very special they can't be
easily repeated
and whilst i'm sympathetic as i'm sure
you are to the circumstances
um in every case that we have an
application in front of the council it
would have been made for good reason
so it's easily repeatable any applicant
would say well i need it they wouldn't
make the application otherwise so that's
the harder one
so there's there's two considerations to
make
and what i'm saying is if you find it's
not inappropriate in the first place you
don't need the second part with the very
special circs
thank you that's exactly what i'm about
to say so i i think
i i'm content that we go with that as a
reason
uh if everybody else is happy as well i
think that's probably the
the best bet now i was making notes so
i've forgotten who proposed
and whose second-hand apologies was it
council edin propose
thank you councillor proposed grant and
uh councillor
oh gosh uh mills seconded didn't he yeah
um
i presume you're both happy with what's
been said
yeah bye mr chairman council um
sorry sorry it's ross chambers here what
you need some conditions clarity what
what are you saying is the reason are
you saying it's
not inappropriate or are you saying it's
not inappropriate
and then we found to be an acceptable
level of development in the green belt
so you don't consider a 72
increase is disproportionate
not on this occasion yeah obviously
being mindful that we know don't set
precedence but on this occasion we don't
find that to be significant
are you okay with that ross i'm just
mindful of uh
you know that's that's quite a big
increase i'm just mindful of how that
could be
you know richard might be able to
comment about how that could be
used elsewhere on on other applications
that's
that's a big increase in insight in
volume
yeah can i just punish it yeah i mean it
is a big
increase some members will recall it
used to be 30
and that was i think councillor jennings
was talking about it would be nice to
have a percentage we don't have that
anymore
therefore i would recommend being
careful about how you interpret the term
disproportionate because as russ has
said
uh there's a lot of people out there's a
lot of pressure on the green belt
and people will look at the council's
decisions
and and use that so
yeah it is i i would say 72 is well
beyond what would be disproportionate
well i i think i think the committee has
made their minds up on this
chaps i think we we're in this case i
think unless somebody wants to indicate
in the chat
they they want to come back and debate
this further
and it looks very quiet
do we well let me mulling that over for
a second
uh could i ask uh richard do you have
any uh a set of
uh conditions that we could put with
this because obviously we need those as
well if we are minded to grant
um yes unless neil's gonna step in with
something i would say the standard
conditions would be the three-year
commencement
yeah they would be the materials to
match the existing
um and i think the approved plans
sorry yeah the approved plan plans and
possibly would we
put on a climate change one richard
uh what's the scale yes i think we would
yeah that would do
yeah it would be to tie it in with with
the submission of what climate change
measures the applicants want
to
thank you okay thank you for that so
we've got a set of conditions uh we now
go back to some speakers who are just uh
coming on the chat so
councillor fleming first please and then
councillor jennings
okay yeah thank you chair um
what's the increase in volume from
what is there now to what the
application is
the reason i'm saying that is that this
kitchen extension
that was built in 1970 it's 50 years old
um if if the house had been built like
that from scratch and we weren't going
to have this extension
even though it's in the green belt we
probably wouldn't be having this
discussion
and i think a 50 year old extension it's
very difficult to keep taking that on to
the original building
and saying it's a it's part of a 79
increase
in in the thing i think i think that's
that's not a practical view that that
some of those extensions are 50 years
old and
i think i mean i know you have to be
rules and there have to be
situations and guidelines but i think
it's it's a bit
difficult for us to justify accepting
the fact
that you're counting a 50 year old
extension as part of an extension on an
original building
that's all i would like to say to you
thank you
do you want me to come back on that mr
chairman if you have anything to add yes
please
just to say that that the council's
policy in the core strategy and the mppf
um we need the comparison to be with the
original building
um and that does you know i can
understand that it seems strange the
original building's 80 more years old
but it's as the green belt existed when
established in 1948 the first green
belts in this country
so it's they're all set at 1948 that's
the original building and that's the
comparison that the
national and local policy require you to
make
thank you thank you richard i appreciate
it uh and good points made by both uh
bill and
richard there um i think this is this is
one of those times isn't it where
uh planning committees are there to
fight make that difficult decision and
define that balance because no
disrespect to any officers
you're doing a a grand job and i
completely get that
it's difficult sometimes to square the
circle when you've got
a piece of legislation set of rules in
front of you that date back 50 or 60 70
years
and you've got to abide by them and i
get that and i
i do feel in this case i personally feel
that
you know granting is not unreasonable um
councillor jennings you indicate that
you'd like to add something at this
point
yeah i know it's just i mean we're
supposed to judge each application on
its own merit
um and i appreciate 72 is a large figure
but if it was a say the size of a garage
sort of 20 square meters and we were
tripling the size of it to 16 square
meters
and it's it's it's still reasonable
but if you had to go use the figures it
would seem like a
it's way out of proportion so i think we
have to have a degree of common sense
in this and i know that ram
i think respect round the back literally
right around the corner from them there
are some
absolutely huge mansions which if they
were to increase by 72 percent would
probably be the size of
the amazon building which they're doing
up the road but uh
it's i think there's got to be a degree
of common sense
and so we have to judge applications on
their own merit
i could just said it better myself
councillor jennings i completely agree
with you
right i think i think we've come to a
conclusion on this
uh nobody else has indicated they want
to speak in the debate
uh we've got a proposition and a second
we also have a set of conditions
i think uh it's time for us to go to the
vote on this one
so with that in mind uh it's proposed
that we grant this application
i'll get the ball rolling counselor
kendall
four thank you chairman councillor crump
i'm staying councillor curtis
councillor curtis four
councillor eden councillored for
councillor fleming caster fleming four
thank you councillor jennings
councillor jennings for councillor mills
council mills for and councillor parry
councillor parry four that's
seven four chairman with one abstention
excellent thank you for that liz
therefore then committee resolves
to grant application twenty slash
zero two eight nine six slash
f u l that is our final application on
tonight's agenda
and i don't believe we have any urgent
business
in which hands thank you very much
thanks liz that case with thanks to
all speakers tonight all the councillors
all the committee members
and to all of our officers thank you
very much and i can declare the meeting
closed
at 8 14. thank you okay